this is Anthony Roth Costanzo on
retainer extraordinaire rehearsing one
of the most challenging pieces in opera
today for six straight minutes
he and his fellow castmates have to sing
the word ah now that seems easy enough
right until you watch it
[Music]
it's an extraordinary feat that happens
roughly one hour into ignite an opera by
Philip Glass about this influential
Egyptian pharaoh anthony plays the lead
pulling off this opera takes the
coordination of hundreds of people
there's dozens of musicians over 60
performers including 12 professional
jugglers there's stage designers makeup
artists a costume with baby heads
attached to them and a giant son roughly
the size of 12 Anthony's oh and the
music is in four different languages
this all happens inside this iconic
building the Metropolitan Opera House in
Manhattan
Anthony's perform dig Naughton with the
English National Opera and the Los
Angeles Opera but this one it's special
I mean come on look at this view it's
pretty awesome and what's even cooler is
we get a peek behind the curtain to see
how it all happens
[Music]
so I play Akhenaten the ancient Egyptian
pharaoh who's a totally fascinating
weird complex guy and he has this idea
which changes the course of history
which is that instead of hundreds of
gods that have existed in Egypt forever
there would be one god and that would be
the Sun he was thus the first
monotheists the first person to worship
one God this opera is like a fever dream
of ancient Egypt and it all starts with
the music which wouldn't exist without
world-class vocal cords these are
Anthony's someone puts a scope down my
throat like this and then when you
breathe they open up should I walk you
through some exercises I don't actually
get that many complaints I can't hear my
own voice the way other ears can because
it's buzzing in my head that's where
Joan comes in it's so much to do with a
way we use our breath she's been his
vocal coach since he was 17 but then we
have to do it without a lip trill and
just starting on a vowel that's the
challenge
[Music]
[Music]
hardest thing in the world is the first
home that first tone is vitally
important during every moment of it none
but especially the scenes where all they
sing is ah
[Music]
so that onset that he did with no
consonant is real accomplishment because
if he did kill himself to understand how
an opera could sound like this you have
to know Philip Glass perhaps the most
famous living composer Philip Glass is a
minimalist so he uses repetition with
changing rhythms and syncopations to
create a kind of meditative state there
are a whole lot of arpeggios meaning a
broken chord so you'll hear Dada Dada
Dada Dada Dada Dada Dada Dada Dada and a
lot of lyrical repetition in opera
there's a beat and the time is king and
you can go ninety percent into your
character but if you go all the way you
might get totally lost and you can't you
can't afford that the first step in not
getting lost is the sits probe so the
zits proba is a german term which zips
means sit and proba means try
[Music]
this is the first time the orchestra and
singers hear what they sound like
together after weeks of rehearsing on
their own it's a kind of sacred moment
and it's also an exciting moment when
you hear the orchestra for the first
time you sing with them for the first
time and in this particular case it's
the Met orchestra they're the best there
are two people in this room who keep
everyone in check Karen and Karen in
western music we have a tendency to
steal time at the end of a phrase here
it's more about thinking linearly and
being really honest about the length of
each rhythmic pattern or an individual
note okay so we did pretty pretty well
Orchestra after about three rounds we
start to slow down so guys playing the
offbeat's
don't listen to anyone because we tend
to get slower I really feel like my job
inside the rehearsals it's again inside
of the conductor's mind to know exactly
what her tempo is
[Music]
it's hard sometimes for performance to
remember in the moment how many repeats
they've done so there's a lot of
counting down measures a lot of this
which means don't sing let me do the
work for you I give a lot of positive
feedback to them to ensure that they're
very comfortable on the stage shall I
start yeah I think you should say so um
yeah this is an opera with a lot of
juggling in it
this is Phelan McDermid and Sean Gandini
he's the director of the Opera and he's
the juggling master one thing is the
performers are moving really slowly it's
true everyone moves in extreme slow
motion the entire performance like this
seen here before Eggman is killed zoom
in to the right side and you see egg
Naughton with Nefertiti and their
daughters it's another one of those
Aussies
move to the left and you see the rest of
the cast moving again in slow motion
the only thing moving fast are the balls
Sean and Karen spent a long time looking
at the score and talking about the
mathematics of how the juggling relates
to the music I spent a lot of time
saying make sure there's a development
you send me that script balls balls
balls out here in the middle of the
whole show there's a hint of a son and
you basically get the sun-god which you
know secretly me and Shawn know that
actually that's the god of the jugglers
it's the biggest juggling ball Big Momma
ball we're about to start I've got a
goal all right I'll see you later this
is the moment I realized the Met stops
for no one hundreds of things are always
happening at once especially at dress
rehearsals where it's all about getting
every last detail right the goal is just
to get out of people's way because
everything is a time to trial over 60
cast members need their makeup done and
there are just a few makeup artists to
have two hours to do it and here's
something I haven't mentioned Anthony
enters the Opera in slow motion and he's
completely naked imagine taking three
full minutes to descend 12 steps looking
straight at 4,000 people and you're
totally naked so it's not just his face
that gets makeup his whole body does
there's also some incredible costumes
and wigs each individual hair is knotted
to a net to make the week I don't like
they have to wear week but he does have
to wear this blue headdress called a
compress that many Egyptian pharaohs
wore to symbolize their royalty there's
always a Cobra on the front it's amazing
and also crap it's like a combo you know
what I mean like this is literally
styrofoam from the stage in the lights
it looks expensive
the real show stealer is this the baby
headdress
if you look at ancient Egypt and the
rituals of ancient Egypt
the Book of the Dead for example is so
fascinating the things they would do
preserve people's organs mummify them
way someone's heart against a feather in
order for them to ascend into the next
life we're representing some of those
rituals in our own way and the shrunken
baby doll heads
somehow evoke that there's a pin the
images from the Book of the Dead also
served as the visual reference for the
multi-level main set to the Metropolitan
Opera is kind of the stage
did you try singing in the house
absolutely not you do it that's a nice
acoustic if I told you you're gonna come
see a minimalist three and a half hour
opera about ancient Egypt where there's
no real story and it's sung in ancient
Egyptian you think man there's no way
I'm going to that and yet I bet you're
gonna love it
[Music]
[Music]